what is an historic day for u.s
diplomacy
president biden is in geneva switzerland
today
to meet with russian president president
vladimir putin at what both leaders
agree
is a low point in relations between the
two countries mr biden has promised a
tough stand
with mr putin whose plane landed in
geneva a short time ago
cbs evening news anchor and managing
editor norah o'donnell is leading our
coverage
in switzerland nora good morning
hey good morning to you anthony here in
geneva president biden is facing
what could be his toughest foreign
policy challenge yet a face-to-face
summit
with a man that he has called a killer
but just this week he also called
president putin bright
and a worthy adversary now all of this
is happening against this beautiful
backdrop an
18th century villa right here on lake
geneva it's actually just across
from where we are right now it's
actually the third time this swiss city
has hosted
us and russian leaders for talks now
today's meeting actually comes
20 years to the day that president
george w bush
met with the russian leader famously
suggesting he had looked putin in the
eye and got a sense of his soul and
found him
trustworthy well i think it is fair to
say that the national security team
around president biden
doesn't think there's much to trust with
putin at all
given that russia has interfered in the
last two presidential elections
and those recent crippling cyber attacks
that originated from inside putin's
country you can see now that
president putin is arriving right now at
that villa his motorcade had just passed
by here there's extremely
tight security here meeting the swiss
president there who we will hear from
shortly you hear the press of course
shouting questions
to them it's unlikely that we will oh
no handshake there interesting i don't
know if that is covid concerns
um but we will see there it is we will
see
uh russian president putin along with
the swiss president and president biden
later this morning before they have some
four to five
hours of talks now we should also note
anthony
the larger geopolitical picture here
because just
this week russia began these naval
drills in the pacific near the coast
of hawaii now it is considered the
latest in what the u.s believes are a
series of provocations against the
united states and that's what's going to
come up at these meetings
ed o'keefe is traveling with president
biden and is at the summit site this
morning and ed we should talk about this
i know there aren't any big agreements
expected today
but do white house officials see this
summit as a way of sending a
very tough message to the russians
well good morning good day uh norah good
day to you from just around the bend
here in lake geneva at this heavily
fortified villa where the president of
russia has now arrived you're correct
white house officials not setting high
expectations
nor expecting any major takeaways but
white house officials do tell cbs news
the president will clearly state
america's national interests and make
clear that any russian actions counter
to them
will be met with a strong response
now in geneva president biden is set to
come face to face with russian president
putin
when asked if he's ready thank you so
much thank you ahead of the meetings
russia sending a provocative message
the country's navy conducting what it
calls its largest military exercise
since the end of the cold war
positioning ships and long-range bombers
about 300 to 500 miles west of hawaii
relations between the u.s and russia are
at a low point with russia-based hackers
targeting two major american businesses
in just the last few months we will
respond if russia continues
its harmful activities final
preparations underway at vila lagrange
right here president biden president
putin and the swiss president
will greet journalists here to cover one
of the most hotly anticipated diplomatic
meetings
in years the meeting is expected to last
at least four to five hours
presidents putin and biden will both be
greeted by the swiss president
who will make remarks and then leave the
two leaders then set to be joined by
their foreign ministers and interpreters
they'll meet for a while and then the
summit will open up to more aids
both men are expected to hold separate
news conferences
among the topics expected to be
discussed today nuclear arms control
russian interference in u.s elections
and cyber attacks
and the white house says the president's
expected to raise the fate of two former
u.s marines being held in russian
prisons
paul whelan and trevor reed
cbs news was first to obtain new audio
of reid
pleading for his freedom i would say
that i spent my whole life in the
service of my country and i would
appreciate it if my country would help
to
bring me home in this difficult
situation back to my family
reed's family said they hope the summit
will bring him one step closer to home
what would be success coming out of this
summit for me it would just be that they
are
making a plan to free him soon it's not
going to happen overnight he's not going
to fly home with the president but
at least that there is some good talks
that they agree
that he will be coming home soon
reed was arrested in 2019 and charged
with assaulting police officers he has
seven years left in his sentence
president putin has suggested a u.s
russia prison swap
prisoner swap but u.s officials say
that's off the table and in remarks this
morning to the russian press putin
spokesman says
among other topics they want to talk
about nuclear arms control
and regaining access to embassies and
diplomatic compounds
in their respective countries nora they
are among several subjects that will be
discussed today
no doubt ed at that very long series of
meetings expected today if you think
about
the number of summits held between u.s
and russian leaders
over the past many decades even here in
geneva it has largely
been about the threat of nuclear weapons
ed
but in this summit there's a different
type of threat that has risen to the top
threat that has risen to the top of the
agenda
and that is cyber warfare right what are
you hearing from white house officials
about what exactly biden will say
to putin about those cyber attacks that
have been launched against the united
states
well a few things nora i mean among
other things now remember just coming
out of the nato meetings there's been
agreement among
members of that military alliance that
they will consider
cyber attacks on countries as a
potential violation of the article five
an attack on one is in a
an attack against all so that could
potentially amplify
the severity of cyber attacks the other
issue to watch for today is conversation
about cyber prisoners or cyber crime
prisoners and whether or not there
should be a swap there that was part of
the confusion
that was generated over prisoner swaps
earlier this week putin suggesting in an
interview that perhaps if there were
cyber criminals in the united states
they could be sent back to russia
the united states says don't worry we
take care of our cyber criminals
he should do the same
all right ed thank you let's send it
back to all of you in new york anthony
norah thank you